My name is Spencer Claeys,
and I specialize in deep cleaning
and removing layers of moss off of roofs.
The area that you live in and the climate
definitely plays a huge factor
into the amount of moss
that grows on roofs.
Up here in the Pacific Northwest,
we have a lot of moss because
there's a lot of rain,
there's not a lot of sunlight,
and there's a lot of trees and stuff
that provide all that material
for the stuff to grow on.
There's probably hundreds
of thousands of species.
But generally, if it's green or black
or something living up there,
it needs to be removed.
So, here, this gutter-guard sponge
was completely grown in,
compacted with mold, moss.
So we need to get it out,
put in some new gutter guards
so that the gutters can be flowing
and working as they should.
The purpose of the gutter guard
is to keep stuff out of the gutters.
This sponge got so grown
in, compacted and stuff,
that we needed to remove it
and put in new gutter guards.
The moss can get up in
between any crack or crevice
that you have up on the
roof and the gutters.
It either grows bigger
and bigger and bigger,
and then water can get
up in there as well, too,
or in the winter too, when it freezes,
it can freeze and expand,
really break that seal that your house
or roof typically has.
So, moss really loves growing
especially on roofs
that have a lower pitch.
When it has a higher pitch,
it has a harder time grabbing
onto a hold of the roof.
But if it's a lower pitch
and it's a lot less steep,
there can be quite a bit more moss
because it has a lot easier time
of getting in between the cracks there.
And generally, you're going to see
a lot more moss growth
on the northern side,
where there's lack of sunlight.
So that's really one
of the biggest factors.
Moss has the easiest time growing
in between asphalt-shingle roofs.
The moss can really get
up in there, grow, expand,
and break the seal of
the shingle for the roof,
and water can get up in there.
More moss, organic material,
and it can cause mold,
and water can get up in
there and damage the roof.
I'll generally start any cleaning process
with the leaf blower and the brush,
getting all that organic material off
before I start treating it.
So, when you see this
level of moss up on a roof,
there's almost no way around.
You gotta get that moss off there.
You gotta brush it off.
Because even if you treat it, it's still,
there's just so much
organic material up there
that the moss is going to
have a really easy time
just regrowing. Once you get rid of it,
it's going to be so much
easier to treat the roof,
keep it from coming back.
I'll use a stiffer nylon brush.
We really want to be
careful when we're brushing.
If you brush too hard,
you can definitely damage the shingles.
But if you're doing it the right way,
you're doing it gently, you
can just get rid of that moss
by just gently kind of flicking it off.
You can leaf-blow it off later.
So, every roof is different.
It really depends on how
established the moss is,
how much moss, what type of moss,
if there's a lot of
trees. That really affects
the amount of pressure that I
use when I'm brushing it off.
Here, I'm using a stick
because the moss is so grown in
that the brush can't even really
get in between the cracks.
And I'll generally
alternate between the stick
and the brush, depending
on the moss level,
depending on what gets
it off the quickest.
I'll follow the leaf blowing
with another hand-brushing,
and this will get everything else
that the leaf blower didn't take care of.
It'll get it loose, and then
we can blow it off later.
Once all the moss is gone
and the roof is clean,
we can begin the treatment process.
When you're treating a
roof, our main purpose
is to raise the alkalinity,
so raise the pH.
And you can do that
with laundry detergent,
you can do that with zinc powder,
and also baking soda you could use.
Sodium hypochlorite, which is like bleach.
And with the treatment,
it's usually a combination
of different chemicals that
I use that raises the pH
and then makes it really hard for the moss
to get established and
come back in the future.
When you see me spraying up there,
that's usually the sodium
hypochlorite, basically bleach,
killing everything up there,
and then the moss-preventative powder.
When I apply the treatment
powder up on the roof,
I really want to be hitting
the peaks really hard,
because that's going to flow
down the roof eventually.
Ledges, gaps, seams, places
around the windows as well.
You want to put a little bit
extra sometimes down there.
The size of the roof really determines
the amount of powder and treatment
I'm going to need to put up on the roof.
When you put the treatment powder on,
you can leave it on there.
You don't really need to touch it.
The rain is going to take
care of the rest for you.
It's going to wash down
over the next couple weeks.
Most cleanings that I do are roofs
that are at least five, 10 years old.
Because moss is so damaging,
I always recommend homeowners
get their roofs cleaned
and treated every year
to uphold the integrity and
longevity of their roof.